serena williams just introduced her baby
girl and we have all the fields on
wednesday the proud new mama shared a
glimpse of her daughter Alexis Olympia
of Hanny and jr. on Instagram almost two
weeks after her birth so we're leaving
the hospital after six complications but
look what we got I got a baby girl
along with baby Alexis's first photo and
name reveal the tennis champ also shared
a montage of memorable moments from her
pregnancies including her first
ultrasound
baby bump selfies and the parents to be
assembling the nursery I made it all by
myself
on Tuesday the 35 year olds hinted that
the first baby pics were coming posting
this pic with her fiance reddit founder
alexis ohanian
with the caption but are you ready I was
really fun on Wednesday alexis shared
this cartoon of his family writing
welcome alexis olympia Ohanian jr. we're
so happy to meet you our little girl is
already momma's perfect sidekick
the couple welcomes their little one on
September 1st
[Music]